[Music]
Pocahontas is a controversial Disney
classic some say the film is problematic
while others think it brought attention
to an important cause either way the
film is artistically gorgeous wanna know
what happened to pick on us after the
movie ended stick around till the end to
see ow
Miko and Percy ended up first time here
smash that subscribe button and don't
forget to like this video now let's see
what happened to Pocahontas after a
happily ever after yes it will be good
to see them again perhaps one day you'll
return to London Pocahontas is
everyone's favorite outdoorsy princess
we all love fluffy dresses in tiaras
but canoeing is pretty epic too we'll
take a cliff diving fishing hunting
princess any day Pocahontas is as tough
as she's smart she doesn't need a prince
to take care of her those aren't her
only awesome traits since she's brave
intelligent compassionate and diplomatic
she's so fantastic that she even has two
guys fighting over her you foger l-- any
woman like that has great things in
store for her future how am I ever going
to find it this awesome leader was the
start of not one but two Disney features
the first movie was a total classic
it gave us Miko and Percy possibly the
cutest duo since Timon and Pumbaa it
also opened a lot of people's eyes to
see how English colonialism may have
felt from the perspective of Native
Americans can you imagine the terror the
Powhatan people must have felt one day
they had never even heard of guns and
the next they were being fired at scary
for a lot of people this was the first
time they heard the story from that
perspective some have said the films
were problematic and included hurtful
stereotypes cultural awareness has
improved since the first film was
released in 1995 maybe some things could
be improved and made more accurate it's
still really important that the movie
made people see the perspective of
oppressed people that makes the film
historically important Pocahontas was
very loosely based on a real woman but
it's definitely an artistic
interpretation the tables are completely
flipped in the second film Pocahontas
travels to England to meet King James
our hero princess manages to save her
people from English
not to mention she finally gets her
fluffy dress moment in pucon is to
journey to a new world the princess
slowly falls in love with John Rahl this
is where the story gets good we've
talked about Disney's Pocahontas is not
a direct representation of her
historical counterpart that means that
what happened to her after she fell in
love with John Rolfe doesn't necessarily
match up to what happened to the real
person so what happens after she hooks
up with her new guy and seals off into
the sunset being in love with a
well-respected English man would be very
complicated for Pocahontas the rules of
the English society were extremely rigid
and puritanical being in love with
someone from a different culture
religion an ethnic group would have been
extremely taboo a lengthy or highly
public courtship would be out of the
question society would never stand for
it the couple shared a scandalous kiss
on the ship headed back to Virginia it's
pretty clear that marriage is on the
horizon they would have never been
accepted into England so America is the
perfect place to start their new life
together
they take the perfect place too after
all Virginia is for lovers Vogon is a
very strong woman you wouldn't let
something as small as getting married
determine the rest of her life we
imagine the couple having homes in both
Jamestown and with Pocahontas is people
the wedding would be a huge
multicultural affair can't you picture
Miko and Percy and matching ruffle
collars how cute is that your best
friend nekoma would obviously be right
by her side and help her plan every
detail the ceremony would have to take
place somewhere special the bonus is a
very spiritual woman she'd want to get
married somewhere she had a serious
connection too we imagine a small
intimate ceremony taking place under
grandmother willows branches wouldn't it
be amazing if John recited his vows in
Pocahontas is native tongue once the
pair were officially married they would
celebrate at a huge reception both
English settlers and indigenous
Americans would come together for this
joyous bash the menu would represent the
union of their two cultures we can't
help but imagine an enormous English
style wedding cake no doubt decorated
with edible leaves to honor the
princesses love of nature after the
wedding married life would treat the
Rolf's really
well they celebrate the birth of a sweet
baby boy Thomas Pocahontas would have a
great time raising children side by side
with her best friend being a mom is hard
but having someone to have playdates
with can be a total blast the royal
family would be important figures in the
colony of Virginia
Pocahontas would serve as a pretty
awesome ambassador for work in Jamestown
would ease a lot of tension between her
people and the English she's been a
peacemaker since she was a teenager that
wouldn't stop after she had her own kids
to look out for in real life John and
Pocahontas only shared one child but the
Disney princess has a different story
she and her husband would also have a
beautiful daughter
she'd grow up to be as beautiful
outspoken and brave as her mother
Pocahontas wouldn't be happy with being
a stay-at-home mom she's just too much
of a go-getter to be fulfilled with life
as a housewife after the bear baiting
incident in the second movie Pocahontas
discovers one of her life's greatest
passions animal conservation her people
highly value sustainable hunting and
fishing practices they recognized the
importance of protecting their resources
Pocahontas would work as an advocate
both in the colonies and England she
would educate people on why things like
bear baiting aren't just good fun she's
never been afraid to speak her mind so
standing up against English culture
would be a breeze she'd also spend years
of her life encouraging sustainable
practices in the colonies the English
settlers were cultivating and building
on her ancestral lands protecting that
land and ensuring it would be beautiful
and thriving for generations would be
extremely important to her not only what
our people's land benefit from these
practices but the English would have an
awesome teacher they could learn so much
from this native expert no one knows the
land better than she does she would
teach them everything they would need to
know about farming hunting fishing and
thriving in her homeland that
relationship would go a long way toward
building a lasting peace between native
peoples and the European settlers seven
years after her wedding Pocahontas would
face a new cultural challenge the
settlers in Virginia would begin to
celebrate Thanksgiving the holiday is
really fun for a lot of people we all
love to sit down with our loved ones and
pig out on turkey and stuffing for some
people the holiday represents more than
just turkey naps and football too many
Native American
Thanksgiving feels like it perpetuates a
lot of hurtful myths in Pocahontas the
English settlers don't arrive as
friendly neighbors they're hostile and
only interested in exploiting the land
for well Thanksgiving is also celebrated
as a holiday of the peaceful
relationship between indigenous people
and European settlers we know that's
just not how it went down
we'd like to think that Pocahontas would
be a voice for reason and compassion
during this awkward holiday there's no
reason why Thanksgiving can't be about
just that giving thanks we all have
things to be grateful for appreciating
what you have and celebrating with your
family are both great things we see
Pocahontas sitting down with her
European neighbors and family and
discussing how her people have struggled
while discussing future peace if anyone
could fix Thanksgiving its Pocahontas so
far everything seems to have worked out
pretty great for our princess she's in
love married living close to her best
friend and raising a family her people
seem mostly at peace with their new
English neighbors don't think for a
second that there isn't some drama in
her life though even someone as down to
earth as Pocahontas is going to have a
few problems hers aren't the worst to
have either be mostly some from having
too many gorgeous men interested in her
sounds really tough right there's no way
you forget about John Smith he's the
hunky blondes that Pocahontas spent her
entire first film hiking and flirting
with no no I need your hand first
[Music]
it's how we say hello
as far as we know he was her first love
they say you'll never forget the first
person you fall in love with in the
second film it definitely seems that our
girl still has a thing for the other
John in her life she's speechless when
she finds out he's still alive the two
are delighted to be together again
Smith is ready to reignite their romance
he tells her that he's thought of her
every day since they last saw each other
how romantic
all of John's dreams come true in the
second film all but one he's given his
own ship and is all but ready to set
sail that minute he steamrollers right
over Pocahontas assuming she'll
obviously just follow along with
whatever he wants but that's not how our
princess operates she was obviously hurt
that he dried her off the rest of her
life without so much as asking what her
plans were maybe that's why she told him
it was time for their paths to go
separate ways that's not where the story
with John Smith ends Pocahontas would
probably make more trips to London to
see her in-laws and continue her work as
an ambassador the chances that she'd run
into John Smith would be high after all
our girl is smart talented and gorgeous
who wouldn't carry a torch for her Smith
is definitely still hung up on his new
world loved Pocahontas obviously still
cared about him even after she thought
he was dead
she only turned him down because his
dreams didn't line up with hers these
two star-crossed lovers would spend the
rest of their lives bumping into each
other on two different continents her
husband probably wasn't a huge fan of
that one Disney fan even wrote a fanfic
about the princess's love for Smith
getting the best of her she's a loyal
woman with a ton of integrity so the
story is a little far-fetched to us
carrying around a crush on your ex is
brutal with everything else going on in
her life this must have been a massive
pain for Pocahontas like she doesn't
have enough to worry about already we
couldn't talk about what happened to
Pocahontas after the credits without
checking in on her too fuzzy friends the
last time we saw Miko and Percy they
weren't showing down on finger
sandwiches and English biscuits after
marrying the wealthy John roll the
spoiling would continue Percy and Niko
have been best friends for a long time
after their rocky beginning in the first
film they soon became like brothers the
prissy pug and
Vaness raccoon do everything together we
imagine the pair begging and scavenging
their way through Virginia and countless
ambassadorial trips from matching
collars to sleeping in matching baskets
the colonies have been good to these fur
balls we're a little worried that they
might develop weight issues later in
life as they play less and continue to
snatch snacks John and his wife would
have to really work to keep their pets
healthy so that's the real end of the
story we watched our princess sail off
into the sunset now we know what
happened when her ship pulled into port
Pocahontas marries the love of her life
in a beautiful ceremony the reception
brings two worlds together she has two
beautiful children and is a loving mom
she continues to work hard for her
people and to be a great ambassador of
her culture
she delicately teaches her people and
their European neighbors how to coexist
she's a fearless warrior for animals she
teaches European settlers the best ways
to live off the land she loves folk
honest is an ambassador activist mother
white and cultural icons
how many Disney Princesses can say that
we hope you love seeing what happened to
this Disney princess after the credits
stopped rolling we'll see you next time
[Music]